ich bestelle einen Burger für 119 Euro
mich hat vor kurzem eine Nachricht
erreicht bei der ich nicht wirklich
glauben konnte was ich sehe weil es gab
einen Burger bei einem lieferrestaurant
für 119 €. was ich nicht glauben konnte
war nicht dass es einen teuren Burger
gibt weil die sind überall im Internet
nein das Besondere ist dass man den
bestellen kann etwas so teures als
liefer Essen anzubieten ist irgendwie
ein bisschen komisch deshalb wollte ich
es testen erstmal danke an Lena die
ZuschauerInnen die mir das zugesandt hat
das Restaurant dass wir heute testen
wollen befindet sich in Aachen und wir
sind erstmal nach Aachen gefahren
[Musik]
dort angekommen haben wir uns überlegt
dass wir uns erstmal einen Eindruck vom
Laden verschaffen wollen weil 119 Euro
sollte man erstens nicht leichtfertig
ausgeben und ich wollte auch einfach
wissen dass das kein Flop ist deshalb
sind wir zum Restaurant hingefahren nur
um eine lockfolie Bestellung zu machen
wir haben uns ein ganz normalen
Cheeseburger mit Pommes bestellt und
haben vor allem erstmal über die Karte
gestaunt weil es gibt nicht nur den 119
€ Burger der besonders ist ein
avocado-burger der kein Brötchen hat
sondern zwei Hälften Avocado anstelle
der Burger Bands ein Oktopus Burger bei
dem man statt einem Patty Tentakel hat
sowieso gab es dort auch natürlich
dieses mittlerweile schon bekannte
schwarze Burger Bann und so und einfach
viele Dinge die man so in einem normalen
Burgerladen nicht finden würde der Laden
machte wirklich einen soliden Eindruck
also aufgeräumt sauber modern alles in
allem nichts was besorgniserre aber
gucken wir uns den Laden auch mal online
an hier sind wir also beim Burger House
und direkt fällt auf vier von fünf
Sternen ist es das was man sehen will
wenn man 119 Euro für ein Burger
ausgeben will nein also 55 hätten mich
auf jeden Fall besser fühlen lassen aber
wir gucken mal rein in die Bewertung 61
gibt es 3,9 ist sogar die Bewertung
Essen war lecker würde mir wünschen dass
es anders transportiert wird damit es
auch noch warm ankommt und das sage ich
euch ehrlich ist auch mein Haupt
bedenken wenn man so einen teuren Burger
liefert dann braucht man doch ein
krasses lieferkonzept wenn ich so viel
Geld ausgebe dann sollte doch bitte
wenigstens warm sein wenn er ankommt
darauf bin ich sehr gespannt an sich
sind die Burger sicherlich gut
allerdings sollte man nicht eine Stunde
Abholzeit angeben in der Burger bereits
nach 20 Minuten fertig ist daher trotz
pünktlicher Abholung war der Burger kalt
und die Zwiebelringe bereits labbrig ja
ihr merkt schon durchwachsen also wie
gesagt das ist eigentlich nicht was man
sehen will wenn man so viel Geld für ein
Burger ausgibt aber dafür haben wir den
Test gemacht der normale Cheeseburger
wurde von uns als gut befunden und wer
uns gedacht so wir bestellen das jetzt
anonym als Lockvogel und haben uns
erstmal einen gemütlichen Parkplatz
gesucht okay jetzt geht's wirklich los
wir haben uns ein gemütlichen Parkplatz
gesucht hier in so einer Nebenstraße
Südstraße heißt das Ganze etwa 10
Minuten vom Laden und bin sehr gespannt
wir werden jetzt die Bestellung tätigen
nicht nur den goldenen Burger den ihr im
Titel gelesen habt wegen dem ihr
wahrscheinlich auf das Video geklickt
habt sondern es gibt noch eine Vielzahl
anderer Burger die wirklich Testens wert
sind weil habe ich so noch nie gesehen
ich weiß nicht was die sich bei der
Zusammenstellung der Karte gedacht haben
aber ich feiere es dass sie einige
Sachen ausprobieren und natürlich bin
ich vor allem auf den goldenen Burger
gespannt stellen wir und gucken wir mal
wie das ganze bei uns ankommt 159 € und
29 Cent und Bestellung abschließen alles
klar teuerste Bestellung ever oder
wahrscheinlich ja und ihr merkt jetzt
sitze ich das muss ich so sagen wirklich
einem meiner Traumautos ein Range Rover
velar das ist mir möglich dank meinem
Partner den ich neu gewonnen habe und
zwar Finn deshalb erzähle ich euch ein
bisschen was zu finden wir haben so eine
kleine Absprache die halten mich mobil
damit ich auch für ein dreh mal nach
Aachen fahren kann ihr müsst euch finden
so vorstellen dass ihr quasi einmal
bezahlt und dafür alles bekommt was ihr
euch so vorstellen könnt ihr mieteten
Auto bei mir hat das keine Woche
gedauert bis ich den Villa da stehen
hatte ihr müsst keine Inspektion Zahlen
ihr müsst keine Versicherung zahlen wenn
ihr Zeit ein festen Preis entscheidet
wie viel Kilometer fahren müsst kriegt
das Auto schnell zur Verfügung gestellt
und hat einfach keine Kopfschmerzen mehr
mit dem Auto Thema die Autos die wir
davor gefahren sind so die waren immer
geliest dieser Autos ich hatte wirklich
keine Lust mehr auf diesen ganzen
Kopfschmerz weil ich wollte einfach ein
Auto haben mit dem ich fahren kann und
mich um nichts anderes kümmern Reifen
selber wechseln Inspektion durchführen
also gerade für alle von euch die
schnell und unkompliziert mobil sein
wollen könnte Finn etwas sein schaut
gerne mal vorbei das Beste ist ihr
kriegt das Auto wirklich vor die
Haustüre geliefert war bei mir auch so
ich kann aus Erfahrung sprechen und mit
dem Code finden 0.3 Max spart ihr auf
die erste Rate 200 Euro unterstützt mich
unterstützt mein Partner und wir lassen
sonst erstmal in diesem wunderbaren Auto
hier schmecken hoffentlich schmecken ne
soll ich selber
man sieht schon direkt jetzt gerade bin
ich wirklich gespannt wie der schmecken
wird auf jeden Fall gesondert verpackt
nicht so wie immer da ist das Ding ne es
ist so skurril aus finde ich wenn man so
in so eine Tüte reinguckt wo man Essen
bestellt hat und dann schimmert einem so
Gold entgegen
159,29 €. Bescheid machen wir mal auf
hier der Lieferant war auch ganz anders
oh lecker im Feuer aber hier ist das
gute Ding 119 € kostet das was ich jetzt
hier gerade in der Hand habe aber sogar
auf dem Patty ist Gold und boah der
Trüffel Geruch der einem hier entgegen
kommt mama mia also das ist wirklich ich
habe das noch nie gesehen ne ich kenne
das nur so von so Youtube von tiktoks
und so ich glaube das ist nicht so ultra
teuer im Einkauf und das Schlimmste was
jetzt passiert sein kann ist dass wir
halt den Laden irgendwie bisschen
Support haben indem wir ihn in Gold
Burger abgekauft haben ich bin mir
sicher ihr wollt dass ich ihn probiere
ich will ihn auch probieren aber erst
die Arbeit dann das Vergnügen das ist
der Oktopus Burger
bitte mach mal schreib mal die Hand aus
Achtung schwer
der kostet ich glaube da ist valu von
money auf jeden Fall gegeben wow das ist
ja wirklich das ist wie auf dem Foto
Leute da ist wirklich einfach Oktopus
drauf ich hätte irgendwie gedacht dass
das so so marketingmäßig ist dann sind
so kleine Schnitzel drauf aber das sind
ja wirklich diese arme drauf es riecht
auch schön frisch also ich hatte so ich
will nichts unterstellen aber ich bei
sowas gucke ich immer lieber erstmal hey
ohne Witz ich hätte gerne Waage dabei
weil ich bin mir sicher dieser Burger
hier wiegt mindestens 500 Gramm ja
wirklich ja und dafür sind 20 € schon
wieder echt gerechtfertigt ich weiß
irgendwie nicht ob ich das gut finde es
ist so komisch für meinen Kopf dass ich
so zögere rein zu beißen so Angst davor
habe ich Angst davor jetzt schon mal
respekt an Burger aus dass sie so
verrückte Sachen machen komm probieren
absolut verrückt weißt du warum das ist
null gummiartig man würde erwarten dass
das vielleicht so gummihaft schmeckt ne
oder das ist übelst cremig das Bann und
das ist ja eine Sache auf die wir
insbesondere beim goldbürger ganz
kritisch schauen werden ist hier super
durchgeweicht ne
aber ich muss auch probieren oder das
Freundschaft hier
aber sag mir dass er nicht krass
schmeckt der Oktopus ist wirklich so on
point gegart die Soßen sind lecker zu
dieser dieser Aioli Knoblauchnote cremig
ist das ganze so alles was auf dem
Burger ist schön angerichtet auf einem
Teller wäre so Normalzeit und
italienischen Restaurant ich kann mir
vorstellen dass es nicht so unfassbar
absichtlich aussieht aber ist es also es
wirklich sehr lecker auch rückblickend
weil dieser Oktopus Burger einfach eine
Wucht ich habe glaube ich selten
irgendein Burger sei es was weiß ich ein
fetter selbstgemachter vom Grill gewesen
der so viel Gewicht hatte der war
einfach massiv das kann man nicht anders
sagen Unterseite bisschen durchgeweicht
aber geschmacklich überraschend
überzeugend da kann man wirklich nichts
machen und ich war sehr gespannt auf den
nächsten Burger kommen wir zum Avocado
Burger
anders als auf dem Foto die beiden
Avocado helfen sind unten drunter muss
man den selbst zu klappen oder
diesen Burger boah das wird ein
Schweinerei wirklich das ist so eine
Schweinerei ich musste drunter kommen
weißt du zack was so meet Lover denken
was veganer essen ich bin gerade voll im
falschen Film das ist so anders als
alles was wir machen aber egal komm
ich frage mich auch ernst so wäre das
bestellt dieses vegetarische Patty was
die haben sehr lecker also das sei ganz
ehrlich also ich bin ganz ehrlich es ist
jetzt nicht so als würde man schlechten
Geschmack im Mund haben hat halt gar
nichts mit einem Burger zu tun man macht
sich übelst die Hände dreckig es
schmeckt auch nicht so besonders
außerordentlich gut okay ja es ist
wirklich glaube ich der Albtraum für ein
Date stell mal vor man sitzt seinem Date
gegenüber leider haben dann Avocado
Burger in der Hand und manchen sich
komplett zu sind quasi der ganze Körper
ist mit Soße bedeckt
aber insgesamt hat sich mir die
Sinnhaftigkeit von so einem Burger nicht
wirklich erschlossen so das ist cool das
sieht gut aus das lockt vielleicht
jemand mit einer Kamera aus Köln rüber
aber es macht eigentlich nicht so
wahnsinnig viel Sinn deshalb für mich
keine Avocado Burger mehr und dann was
soweit ein 119 € für ein Burger vom
Lieferservice wenn ich irgendwie auf
einem goldenen Tablette serviert wird
nein in einer silbernen Aluschüssel mit
einem Plastikdeckel das war so eine
skurrile Situation dass ich wirklich so
wenn ich jetzt weiter drüber nachdenke
erst checke wie absurd das eigentlich
war ich saß einmal im Kofferraum habe
diesen Burger gegessen aber das
entscheidende soll natürlich vor allem
der Geschmack sein ob es sich für mich
lohnt ob es mir schmeckt das finden wir
jetzt heraus wollen wir mal reingucken
hier ist also und was ich jetzt schon
wertschätze ist die gesonderte
Verpackung siehst du hier steht keine
Feuchtigkeit drin das ist nämlich genau
das was ich dachte ich dachte mir so
wieso so einen Burger als Lieferangebot
machen weil liefern kann ihm ja niemals
gut tun aber immerhin das war meine
große Sorge dass der für 120 € so zermat
ankommt ich bin wirklich sehr sehr
gespannt das ist kein normales Patty ne
was wir daraus sehen so das ist so nicht
so rund geformt und so ich bin echt
gespannt aber ich weiß nicht ob
aufmachen so viel bringt
ich werde jetzt nicht auseinander
klettern aber ich kriege ja schon so
Gold an meine Finger augen zu und durch
Hände schmutzig bzw golden machen
Attacke
das ist Filet ne das ist Rinder
zeig noch mal richtig seht ihr das ja ne
man merkt das voll beim Beißen also die
Zähne müssen auch wenn es viele ist
natürlich viel mehr arbeiten aber dafür
ist natürlich der Rind Geschmack viel
viel intensiver was aber dominiert und
das gibt dem Ganzen auch so diesen
luxuriösen Touch wieder ist diese
trüffelsoße weil die ist wirklich sehr
intensiv du hast das Gefühl so wirklich
trüffelbombe zu essen
bin ich gut aber es schmeckt es schmeckt
gut schmeckt wirklich gut aber ein
Rinderfilet ist untypisch
du musst wirklich so beißen so durch das
rinderfilette das ist scheiße findest du
nicht gut ja okay ich fühle was du
meinst aber geschmacklich ist das halt
rewarding ne ja also wir verputzen alles
wird nichts weggeworfen und sie sehen
uns dann mit ein bisschen Abstand im
Büro wieder aber vollkommen verrückt es
sind fast 24 Stunden vergangen und der
erste Eindruck nach dem Dreh war dann
relativ rasch so es geht uns jetzt nicht
so gut das könnte auch daran liegen dass
wir Octopus Avocado Gold durcheinander
gegessen haben geschmacklich stehe ich
dazu war der super lecker die
Entscheidung mit dem Filet weiß ich
nicht da ist irgendwie ein schönes vagio
Patty oder sowas glaube ich geeignetter
weil man will ja auch so dieses
Mundgefühl von einem Burger haben das
hat safe darunter gelitten das ist halt
ein Steak war ist es das für mich Wert
ja aber nur weil ich dieses Video
gedreht habe privat never würde ich mir
nicht holen ich bin dankbar für die
Erfahrung schaut an an den Laden dass
sie sich was trauen dass sie nicht
Standard Produkte anbieten dass sie neue
Wege gehen das feier ich sehr danke an
euch fürs zuschauen es gibt hier ein für
dich vorgeschlagenes Video welches du
die angucken kannst du kannst aber auch
du kannst auch den Kanal abonnieren
danke schön und bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao ciao